[MUSIC]
Raise your hand if you graduated college.
Pretty much everyone.
If you raise your hand,
I want you to take a moment.
Take a moment and reflect on the impact
that that degree is hard on your life.
The network get enabled the opportunities
that it's pulled into reach.
Now, I want you to imagine
your 18 year old self.
Imagine I told them,
you couldn't go to college.
That circumstances have changed and
it wasn't an opportunity for you.
How would you feel?
What would you do?
How would you build a career or
design your resume if you
couldn't start with education?
This is my first time at college.
Now, don't worry,
I didn't lie on my Stanford application.
At age 18, I started working
in London as an apprentice.
I learned and earned.
I trained as an accountant whilst
working full time in restructuring.
Fast forward eight years and
here I am, still on stage at
Stanford Graduate School of Business,
an evidence that you can go extraordinary
places with an untraditional path.
I succeeded because of
my own traditional path.
But it was hard.
It was hard because of prejudices and
attitudes that exist in society,
prejudices and
attitudes that exist in this room today.
Business leaders, parents and teachers are
sending the wrong signal to young people,
the signal that the only route
to success is a college degree.
Let me tell you a story.
Shortly after my promotion to
manager at a top consulting firm,
I was rushing from one
meeting to the next.
I ran into one of my favorite
high school teachers.
We chatted and he asked me the inevitable,
the dreaded question.
Where did you go to college?
I didn't, I replied, I'm an apprentice.
But before I could finish my sentence, I
saw looking at disappointment in his eyes.
I've lost track of the number
of times I've been told.
You need to go to college to get a good
degree or you had so much potential.
Rather than celebrating the successes of
people that have taken an untraditional
path, we often make them feel inadequate.
Despite my professional success,
I often feel inadequate.
So you might be sat there wondering,
well, why should I care?
And I say you should care for two reasons.
As future business leaders,
you are going to miss out on great talent.
And as humans, you have a responsibility
to the young people in your lives.
So because I'm an MBA student, I'm
going to start with a business case and
then talk about the human case.
So the business case,
we are in an employee market,
organizations are struggling
to fill their ranks.
In 2015,
5 million US jobs went unfilled, but
8.5 million Americans were looking for
jobs.
Anybody else see the mismatch?
Talented people locked
out of the workplace.
Workplaces struggling to
find talented people.
It is in no one's best interest to
only recruit from traditional paths.
By broadening your criteria,
you're opening yourself to capable and
diverse candidates.
80% of job applications in the United
States ask for an associate's degree or
higher if 42% of high school
sophomores graduate college.
Do you see the mismatch?
I get it, it's hard to drive change.
It is hard to open up systems that
include non-traditional backgrounds.
It's hard, but it's doable.
And you can't afford not to.
By opening up your recruitment criteria,
you
are giving yourself a competitive talent
advantage in this tight employment market.
Why not be the first mover
in this current talent war?
Now, let's talk return on investment.
I urge you to become the creators and not
just the consumers of tomorrow's talent.
By that, I mean, we all have
a responsibility to not just use skills,
but build skills.
There is more than just
a business case for
employing people with
an untraditional background.
There's a business case to
build apprenticeship programs.
And this business case is built upon
the value added work that you will get
from teams that work on your projects.
It's from the value adds that
is given from diversify teams.
We know that there is return on investment
that comes with apprenticeship models.
It has been proven, and it's been proven
to come in as little as 18 months.
So although that there is costs
associated with apprenticeship programs,
things like wages, training costs and
program management fees, you will
see a positive return on investment.
Businesses need to push
change from the top down.
As humans,
we need to push change from the bottom up.
College for
all is disadvantaging many young people.
It is having a detrimental effect on
those that learn better by doing.
It's disadvantaging those
that don't have the means or
the opportunity to attend college.
Apprenticeship programs allow
people to learn and earn.
Giving opportunities to people
from all walks of life.
Apprenticeship programs can be
undertaken in healthcare, construction,
finance, technology, media, even law,
there is more than one way to success.
There are multiple paths, but
they're currently underfunded and
under recognized.
We are over indexing on one.
So my ask to you as future business
leaders is, why miss out on great talent?
Why not push for change and
put your money where your need is?
Why not develop programs to hire and train
the future leaders of your organization?
And as humans,
we need to challenge our elitist attitudes
that equate not having
a degree to not being capable.
We need to recognize that
apprenticeship programs and
work experience are just as
valuable as college degrees.
So I'm going to leave you
with three challenges.
I challenge you to change the way you
think about non-traditional backgrounds.
I challenge you to change
the way you talk about success.
And finally,
next time a resume crosses your desk,
I challenge you not to jump
straight to education but instead,
dig into experience, and
benefit from a diverse, young workforce.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]